there is one week left of early voting
in the general election a local group
encouraging latino women to send in
their ballots
kate houston went to a rally outside the
lord's george
lloyd george courthouse excuse me where
organizers are hoping to empower latino
voters me familia vota is
bringing latino women together from all
across the community and they hope that
tonight's rally
will encourage them to vote in the
general election nifamilia votas says
research shows that latino women are
less likely to feel excited and
empowered to vote by mail
the group is encouraging latino voters
to send their ballot through the mail
due to safety concerns over kovid 19 and
because it can be more accessible for
those who are working
if we're not educating and empowering
our community no one else is going to do
it
so like we like i want to make sure
everyone knows that we're as
accessible as possible also at tonight's
rally councilwoman olivia diaz
immigrant justice corps fellow paloma
guerrero and assemblywoman selena torres
we know that our vote is going to win
even more than it has before
but it's not going to do that if we
don't cast our ballots
so what we need to do is make sure that
every latino vote
gets counted our voices strong in this
community
and our voice is stronger when we vote
according to pew research center there
are a record 32 million latinos
projected to be eligible to vote in this
election
that will account for more than 13
percent of all eligible voters
houston 8 news now